because she can cook
that ain't what I said oh firstly that's
not what she said to be fair be fair
secondly I'd be with the 10 out of 10
hook because I'm top jeep but to make
the point I think what you have to
understand is what men are looking for
in a relationship so you did the the
street interview and you're asking
single people probably young people
probably idiots you know they're on
camera talking [ __ ] about good head all
this garbage is [ __ ] what men are
interested in in life not just in their
relationship but in their life as a
whole is status I don't think most
people understand especially women how
competitive the male world is and how
competitive it is for status this is why
men do everything they do men buy the
faster car not to drive any faster
because of status that's why I want a
bigger house we don't give a [ __ ] where
we live it's because static so I want to
go to the gym and get big and strong
because of status everything we do is
about status is why I want the better
job so I want more money so I want to be
respected